(dreamy mysterious music)
- [Host] Easter Island isn't
the only place in the world
with some mysterious stone faces.
In the highest peak of the
Eastern Taurus mountain range
in Turkey lies Nemrut Dag.
Nemrut Dag is a temple
tomb believed to be built
by the late Hellenistic King Antiochos.
He reigned from 69 to 34 BC
and built the temple
to commemorate himself.
The monument features statues of the king,
lions, eagles, and various
Greek, Armenian, and Medes gods,
with each measuring almost 30 feet tall.
The heads of these
sculptures once sat atop
their stone bodies, but at some point
in time, they were removed.
Nemrut Dag went lost to memory
until it was rediscovered
by a geologist in 1881,
and in 1987 it was designated
a UNESCO World Heritage Site.
And while there are those that believe
these figures hold a deep
mythological significance,
how these stone structures
were physically constructed
without modern tools is a mystery.
(echoing digital beep)